it's been described as the world's
biggest corruption scandal involving
more than five billion dollars worth of
illegal payments that so far embroiled
Brazil's current and former presidents
at least two other former South American
leaders and key members of Brazil's
business elite many of whom are now
making the adjustment from billionaire
lifestyle to a life behind bars it's
gone hand in hand with Brazil's worst
recession in decades but there has been
a silver lining to all this chaos at the
heart of the scandal are two corporate
giants Petrobras Brazil's state
controlled oil company and Odebrecht
Latin America's largest engineering firm
[Music]
Petrobras awarded building contracts to
Odebrecht and other smaller companies
these companies in cahoots with
Petrobras would overcharge on the true
cost of the work some Petrobras
directors would turn a blind eye and 3%
of every deal would be siphoned off into
a joint slush fund which accumulated
millions of dollars these funds were
laundered in a variety of small scale
businesses such as car washes and petrol
stations and then used to finance
political campaigns and bribe
politicians in an attempt to win or
influence government policy
in 2014 a mundane police inquiry into
small-scale money-laundering businesses
uncovered a web of corruption the
investigation codenamed Operation car
wash revealed a flow of money all the
way from a number of Petrobras and
Odebrecht executives to politicians at
the very top of the political system and
once exposed it began a reckoning that
brought those involved to justice
Lulla brazil's popular former president
was found guilty of receiving an
apartment worth around $700,000 he's
appealing against his near 10-year jail
sentence in June 2017 Brazil's current
president Michel temer was charged with
corruption as well however the lower
house of Congress has voted not to
proceed with the charges and although
Tammuz predecessor Dilma Rousseff II
hasn't been directly linked to the
corruption scandal the investigation
clouded her presidency she was impeached
in 2016 for deceptive accounting of
government funds the vast scale of the
scandal soon unfolded today more than 80
sitting Brazilian politicians are now
under investigation and the scandal has
spread to 16 countries across four
continents implicating other leaders and
politicians Peru's former president
Alejandro Toledo is a fugitive with a
warrant out for his arrest
he's accused of taking bribes from
Odebrecht another of Peru's former
presidents Ianto Amala has been detained
together with his wife for alleged money
laundering linked to the scandal and the
company's at the heart of the scandal
since September 2014 the total value of
Petra brasses shares has decreased by 80
billion dollars at the end of 2016 the
US Department of Justice fined Odebrecht
2.6 billion dollars for the bribery
scheme and billionaire CEO Marcelo
Odebrecht is currently serving a 19 year
jail sentence the scandal has compounded
the worst recession on record to make
life very hard for many in Brazil 13.5
million people are unemployed and the
country's GDP is still 9% below its
pre-recession peak
but the scandal has also brought hope
for while allegations of bribes and
kickbacks are nothing new in Brazil this
time the corrupt are paying the price
for their actions because of this
ninety-six percent of Brazilians want
the investigation to continue
they hoped finally holding the corrupt
to account will weaken the blight of
corruption in their country there are
even calls for Sergio Moro the federal
judge overseeing the investigation to
run for president in 2018 the
investigation has had a silver lining
it has laid bare the financial foul play
at the heart of a Brazilian state but it
has also illustrated the maturity and
independence of Brazil's justice system